bien déchirer on a deux héros d'x files
qui sont avec nous ce soir
applaudissements pour mathieu mulder et
maxime skalli
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est rentré à temps c'est celle que je
que je me tape dans la série en fait
bien même elle vient ma fille regarde
chaque touche à ton cul temps a dit mary
c'était quoi la mise en scène et j'ai
pas compris c'est une mise en scène on
joue un peu des scènes de x files ils en
avaient été les 6 minutes avant dans les
loges il m'a dit on met en scène je
faire une entrée et tout un homme et lui
c est après mon brave aubry avec kelly
gratuit la quête avec lequel idracula
[Applaudissements]
si kanye dracula mer